patrick en jeu raul bonjour bonjour
bienvenue dans la matinale de rtl france
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors votre protégé votre profession
plutôt discrète un d'habitude a décidé
de se mobiliser demain vous estimez
maltraité par le gouvernement pourquoi
parce qu'il ya un nombre de mesures qui
ont été prises déjà depuis plusieurs
années un c est ça s'est accentué
ingérer à partir de 2018 2019
avec ce qu'on a appelé les
expérimentations clame alors je dirais
les principaux points sur lequel on bute
c'est d'une part la systématisation
d'une prescription médicale qui sont
tout à fait contradictoire avec les
modes d'intervention dans lesquels on
est le plus souvent et la qualification
qui est la nôtre la sous tarification 1
puisque les modèles que ça soit comment
les ex qu'on appelait les
expérimentations clame que ça soit le
check up six étudiants que ça soit le
100% enfants sains que ça soit même une
partie des propositions msp c'est aux
alentours de 30 euros la consultation
donc voilà et puis il ya quelque chose
qui a été un petit peu un déclencheur de
cette mobilisation c'est un arrêté du 10
mars sur ce qu'on appelle les troubles
neurodéveloppementaux où sont imposés
d'une certaine manière des méthodes et
ce qu'il répond absolument pas au
pluralisme dans lequel s'inscrivent les
les psychologues alors effectivement là
cette mobilisation cet appel du 10 juin
comme on l'a nommé a mis en place par
quatre organisations a été comment
cosignée à tout le moins il ya eu la
mobilisation de plus de 100 associations
syndicats et organisations
professionnelles de psychologues
la manifestation est nationale et qu'on
y compris les dom tom puisqu'il ya
environ une quarantaine de villes dans
lesquelles les psychologues vont aller
manifester devant les ars en particulier
où les préfectures 1 c'est pour dire
effectivement l'intensité du malaise
c'est une profession qui est plutôt
discrète qui est en général comment
comme on peut je dirais sur la scène
publique
et là on a
finalement une commande une espèce de
mal être extrêmement profond lié à ces
orientations qui sont prises depuis
quelques temps et l'échec des
négociations dans lesquelles on est avec
le gouvernement et comment justement
vous comprenez le contrôle finalement du
gouvernement sur sur votre profession
commence que vous les expliquer alors je
ne sais pas quand fin je dirais qu'il ya
une accentuation un petit peu à ces
derniers temps c'est c'est un débat qui
existe depuis bien des années au sein du
de la corporation de du métier 1 parce
que comment il ya une volonté un petit
peu médical du côté du ministère de la
santé 1 d'avoir un petit peu en prix sur
cette profession là le coc vide et la
crise sanitaire a augmenté finalement la
visibilité et la demande
elle est apparue finalement la
souffrance des populations et leurs
besoins
inde à voir comment des consultations
d'avoir finalement une écoute un site
serait bien sûr la dimension des coûte 1
qui n'est pas uniquement une position
techniciste inde
l'intervention des psychologues et puis
il ya effectivement une raréfaction des
médecins généralistes dans certaines
régions une raréfaction des psychiatres
un déplacement un petit peu de la
demande
et puis il ya des orientations aussi
plus généraliste parce qu on aurait pu
se dire au fond il suffisait de recruter
un peu plus de psychologues
comment dans les institutions mais
effectivement il ya une externalisation
finalement un des des postes qui est qui
existait dans les cnp dans les
structures hospitalières dans le
médico-social vers le libéria et là je
pense que c'est une orientation
politique bien particulière et qui vient
à ce moment là comment mettre en
question est un besoin de contrôler
qu'un besoin de contrôle budgétaire est
ce qu'on peut bien entendre mais aussi
un besoin de contrôle médical qui nous
semble tout à fait inadaptée qu'est ce
que vous demandez du coup aujourd'hui au
gouvernement soit dans ce contexte là on
lisait vous êtes de plus en plus
sollicités après cette crise sanitaire
oui alors ce qu'on ce qu'on demande
c'est bas d'une part
comment la la suppression un petit peu d
orientation ou des différents arrêtés
parce qu'il y en a aussi sur l'oncologie
sur l'alzheimer sûr je voulais dit les
troubles neurodéveloppementaux on a même
déposé il ya eu plusieurs recours déposé
en contentieux déposés au conseil detat
contre l'arrêté du 10 mars c'est pour
vous dire combien c'est extrêmement
problématique de reprendre une
concertation où sont entendus
véritablement les attentes est reconnue
aussi la compétence des psychologues
parce qu'il ya spes de remise en cause
sans arrêt dans les discours officiels
un des compétences de la formation fin
bon et est de permettre véritablement à
la profession de pouvoir s'organiser
pour répondre aussi aux attentes et aux
besoins de la population pourquoi parce
que ce qui la conséquence principale
c'est que les conditions de prise en
charge de la population se dégrade
c'est à dire que le sait pas tant la
profession wagon la profession à ses
soucis ses revendications c'est pas bien
étonnant à mener c'est surtout la
qualité d'accompagnement qui va être qui
est ce qui va en pâtir le plus bas c'est
principalement le public mais les
personnes qui sont dans des situations
de souffrance pour des raisons x ou y
qui sont difficultés à un moment donné
qu'ils sont dans une impasse de vie
sains vont pas trouver là des conditions
d'accompagnement qui leur sont
nécessaires
et justement qu'est ce que vous avez
observé comme apparition de nouvelles
souffrances finalement chez les français
après cette crise sanitaire
alors je pense qu'il ya la crise
sanitaire a été une espèce de
condensation de d'un mal être un peu
plus généralisée dans le lien social
les formes les plus classiques c'est
bien sûr j'irai toutes les expressions
dépressive qui vont je dirais de 10
d'idées suicidaires à des formes de
décompensation sur des lignes de
fragilité 1 dont les personnes sont
porteuses à a
une irritabilité à des conduites de
repli d'isolement à des plaintes
commencent très souvent un petit peu
d'ordre somatique à une fatigabilité à
des difficultés relationnelles avec une
augmentation des tensions intra
familiales en particulier enfin voilà il
ya toute une palette finalement un de
difficultés qui se sont majorées un de
façon très très nette à ea sonde de
commandes d'études
comment statistiques en particulier de
santé publics français ont très bien
montré l'augmentation notable des formes
dépressive dans l'ensemble de la
population et en particulier chez les
plus jeunes et dans ce contexte est ce
que la france manque de psychologues
finalement aujourd'hui alors je serai
pas tant qu'elles manquent de
psychologues
il ya à peu près comment si on suit les
les
comment les les notes un petit peu de
l'adresse de la grèce il ya à peu près
presque 80 milles psychologue entre 70
et 80 milles 1 puisqu'il aider des cas
il y en a je dirais une vingtaine 2001
qui sont tout à fait compétent 1 pour
faire de l'accompagnement psychothérapie
coup je veux dire de la clinique de la
souffrance en règle générale sur des
champs extrêmement différents je pense
qu'on a les psychologues qui sont
nécessaires mais simplement
effectivement il faut pouvoir organiser
les modalités d'accompagnement est alors
j'irai la bonne idée du gouvernement 1
parce que pas non plus être uniquement à
charge
c'était ce principe de remboursement un
cesser cet accompagnement et cette prise
en charge par la société un des
difficultés de la population
sauf que les conditions pour les
professionnels sont inacceptables et ne
permettent pas d'ailleurs pour les gens
qui seraient installés en libéral 1 ce
qui est le cas de beaucoup de dunes fin
d'une bonne part de la population
actuellement ne permettent pas des
conditions de viabilité au long cours 1
c avec des tarifs pareil on paie pas ses
charges n'arrive pas à faire face a et
c'est une précarisation un d'une
certaine manière de la de la profession
merci beaucoup patrick en jeu
moi qui vous remercie et notre
invitation je le rappelle vous êtes
secrétaire général du syndicat national
des psychologues